[Aplausos]
mi nombre es jennifer polanco y te tengo
una pregunta alguna vez has tomado una
decisión que todos sus amigos y
familiares creen que es estúpida pero
que tú sabes que es la decisión correcta
para ti que levante la mano
ahí estuve yo hace unos años pero déjame
empezar por el principio por mucho
tiempo yo traté de adaptarme a las
normas sociales que dicen que las
mujeres tenemos que seguir los tipos de
viajes que dicen que las mujeres tenemos
que tener a alguien que nos acompañe
para viajar con nosotros hasta que un
día me canse cuando me gradué de la
universidad decidí tomar un trabajo
totalmente diferente al que estudié en
mi carrera un trabajo en el departamento
de ventas porque sabía que ésta era el
departamento que más dinero hacía en la
empresa cuando aplique para ese trabajo
iba a hacer tres cosas tres eran mis
objetivos número uno pagar mis deudas
número dos ahorrar dinero para viajar
por tres meses y número tres renunciar a
este trabajo exactamente en
tuve todo un año planeando cómo iba a
ser mi carta de renuncia que le iba a
decir al jefe tenía todo planeado y
puedes creer que exactamente el día que
se suponía que yo iba a renunciar me
temblaban las manos el corazón latía
fuertemente y me llegaron mil y unas
dudas de las cosas que me podrían pasar
mar en este viaje qué tal si te matan
qué tal si cuando regreses ya no puedes
encontrar un trabajo como el que temía
que tal tu novio qué vas a hacer con él
habían tantas dudas en mi cabeza que
durante todo el año que yo estaba
planeando mi renuncia nunca me llegaron
hasta ese momento en el que yo tenía que
tomar acción para hacer realidad mis
sueños
pero no deje que las dudas me detuvieran
sino que seguí con mi plan y renuncie
esta tarde luego salí con mis amigas y
les conté lo que había hecho me dijeron
que estaba loca y las mismas preguntas
que me había hecho yo todo el día me lo
hicieron ellas y por qué dejar un
trabajo tan seguro para viajar porque no
solamente te conformas con dos semanas
al año y te vas a un lugar bonito
acompañada con alguien qué tal si te
violan y qué tal si te matan qué tal si
te secuestran y todas esas preguntas que
nos preguntan a las mujeres que queremos
viajar sola y la verdad ni yo misma
tenía la respuesta luego esa misma noche
salí con mi novio y le dije lo que había
hecho en ese momento terminó conmigo
entonces ahí estaba yo con un corazón
roto sin trabajo sin novio y sin rumbo
exactamente donde no quieres estar
cuando comienzas tu vida de adulta sin
embargo ya no había vuelta atrás así que
seguí con mis sueños pero igualmente
todas las dudas siempre llegaban a mi
cabeza ya no había vuelta atrás
así que utilice una aplicación de viajes
en la que puedes poner tu ciudad y luego
pones a cuáles ciudades puedes ir y ver
cuáles son los vuelos más baratos el
viaje más barato fue a cartagena
colombia y nuevamente ahí vinieron todas
las dudas qué vas a hacer tú sola en
colombia y quitar los estereotipos que
tiene ese país y si te violan si te
matan si si te secuestran todas esas
dudas llegaron a mi cabeza sin saber que
este iba a ser uno de mis viajes
favoritos
así funciona el miedo el miedo te para y
no te hace pensar en las cosas que te
pueden pasar bien si no en todas las
cosas que te pueden pasar mal sin
embargo seguir seguí con mis sueños y
seguir viajando porque ya no había
vuelta atrás así que compré ese boleto
de una vía a cartagena colombia
empaque una maleta de mano y dejé todo
todo lo conocido para seguir el sueño de
viajar sola un sueño que realmente ni yo
misma podía explicar viaje a ver si está
el vídeo
vivía aventuras
explore ciudades que nunca imaginé que
iba a visitar conocí a muchísimas
personas que me trataron como si yo
fuera su hija y durante este viaje
aprendí tanto pero lo más importante que
aprendí es que la sociedad nos dice qué
tipo de viajes tenemos las mujeres qué
hacer pero lo que no nos dice es que
nosotros como siguen fuertes nos hacen
creer que las mujeres somos el sexo
débil pero en realidad somos el sexo más
fuerte que las mujeres tenemos una
ventaja al viajar que los viajes que y
verán que te ayudan a vencer tus propios
miedos abrir nuevos seres antes a dejar
de compararte con la chica de al lado
amar sus diferencias y lo más que te
aprendí desde viajes hola está aprender
a amarme más a mí misma hasta ver que no
dependo de ningún hombre para poder
viajar y para poder seguir mis sueños
aprendí todo esto pero piénsalo si yo
hubiera dejado que el miedo me dejara
ganar si me hubiera dejado ganar que
hubiera pasado no hubiera vivido ninguna
de esas experiencias y así funciona el
miedo y así muchísimas otras mujeres
también paralizan sus acciones de lograr
sus sueños solamente por el miedo y no
la culpa es que de estas chiquitas a las
mujeres nos enseñan que tenemos que
seguir un patrón un patrón específico
por ejemplo nos dicen bájate de ahí que
te vas a caer o deja de jugar con este
camión citó mejor juega con esos
juguetes de cocina que son para niñas o
deja eso esos de hombres o párate
derecha bájate el vestido cuidado que se
ven esos pantaloncitos que te pusieron
debajo
esos mismos pantaloncitos que te
pusieron de niña para que tú seas libres
para que tú puedas saltar y disfrutar
pero sin embargo ahora tienes que estar
derechita y no moverte para que no se
vean
y así es que funcionan los miedos
mientras que a los hombres les enseñan a
tomar riesgos a subirse en árboles o
déjalo él es un niño entonces cuando
crecemos las mujeres estamos
acostumbradas a evitar los miedos a
evitar tomar es hacer lo que tú quieras
porque tienes el temor deja eso eso es
mejor para hombres mientras que los
hombres están entrenados a tomar riesgos
entonces cuando crecemos las mujeres
estamos bien precavidas de todas las
cosas que vamos a hacer
y ahí seguimos los hombres están
entrenados a tomar están entrenados a
tomar riesgos y ser valientes la falta
de valentía es lo que hace que no hayan
tantas mujeres en la política en los
negocios y en los altos rangos de la
sociedad y es esta razón también que
hace que las mujeres que haremos menos
que los hombres pueden creer que las
mujeres tendemos a no negociar nuestros
salarios por el miedo a que nos vayan a
rechazar este trabajo mientras lo
primero que hacen los hombres es
negociar su trabajo negociar su salario
para así tener mejores salarios y esto
se debe a que las mujeres tendemos a
tener miedo de ser evaluadas como que
estamos tratando de ser hombres como un
estudio de la universidad de harvard
si me ponen el powerpoint
que dice que la percepción de que las
mujeres tenemos que parecer amables y no
parecer exigentes son las que explica la
resistencia de las mujeres a negociar
sus salarios ellos prefieren ganar menos
que tener que negociar sus salarios
ahora me pregunto yo no me imagino mi
vida que hubiera sido sin esos tres años
viajando sola aprendí muchísimos flores
lugares que nunca imaginé explorar pero
no creas que todo fue color de rosa o
que todo se da color de rosas para ti
por ejemplo estuve a punto de la muerte
cuando estuve viajando por el medio
oriente medio' apendicitis y tuve una
cirugía de emergencias
lejos de todos mis familiares de todos
mis amigos de todo lo conocido en un
idioma totalmente diferente al mío la
verdad ni siquiera entendía a los
doctores pero yo no puedo dejar que esa
experiencia me pare yo seguir viajando
sola y como a mí lo más seguro a ti
también te va a pasar muchas cosas que
no estaban planeadas en el camino a
llegar a tus sueños pero no puedes dejar
que ese pensamiento de lo que te podría
pasar
te pare a tratar de
dejar tus sueños realidad
luego de ese viaje
estuve mucho tiempo explorando me a mí
misma y viendo cuáles son las cosas que
realmente me gustan no solamente las
cosas que no dice la sociedad que nos
quiere que gustar sino todas estas cosas
que nos hace felices
ahora qué vamos a hacer que podemos
hacer nosotros para que esto cambia
número uno empecemos desde la casa con
nuestras niñas con nuestras hijas con
nuestras hermanas con nuestros
familiares ya no hay juguetes para niñas
y juguetes para niños hay juguetes y que
sean los niños y las niñas quien elijan
qué tipos de juguetes quieren jugar ese
día número 2 motivamos a las niñas a
tomar riesgos e incentivar los fracasos
porque mantenernos en una burbuja no nos
está haciendo o ayudando ha prosperado
para el mundo laboral sino que lo que
está haciendo es poniendo miedo en
nosotros tanto miedo que tenemos tanto
miedo al fracaso que no lo sabes por
nuestras metas
y número 3 si creciste en una sociedad
donde los hombres tenían los pantalones
es hora de abrir los ojos y exigir
nuestro derecho que ya no somos las
mujeres sumisas que somos capaces
independientes y que podemos hacer y
vivir todo lo que queramos
yo realmente no me imagino es la vida
viajando sola sin esa vida de sueños
esta vida que si yo hubiera dejado que
el miedo me ganara nunca lo hubiera
podido vivir entonces que tú vas a hacer
que tú vas a ser el día de hoy para
comenzar a hacer realidad tus sueños que
no se queden solamente en un sueño sino
que se conviertan en realidad
algunas veces yo me pregunto qué hubiera
sido de mi vida si hubiera dejado que el
miedo me ganara si hubiera dejado que el
miedo a dejar un trabajo estable a dejar
a mi novio a dejar todas las cosas
conocidas
yo hubiera dejado que este miedo me
parará a hacer realidad uno de mis
sueños te puedo asegurar que lo más
seguro no hubiera estado aquí parada la
noche de hoy y lo más seguro no hubiera
comenzado este blog que compuse para
inspirar a mujeres a viajar solas y no
ver es cerrada a todas las mujeres a que
sigan sus sueños y lo más seguro también
cuando se habilita me hubiera preguntado
qué hubiera pasado de mi vida si no
hubiera decidido a tomar el riesgo de
seguir mis sueños
gracias a dios no sé si valentía pero
tuve las agallas de seguir mis sueños y
tú
cuáles experiencias estás dejando de
vivir en estos momentos simplemente por
el temor a perseguir tus sueños
[Aplausos]